all right guys
bang bang uh i've got a special treat
today
uh which is a little bit different uh i
have a gentleman
who goes by uh the name john street
capital
on twitter but uh he's not gonna tell
you who he actually is
um but definitely if you follow on along
on twitter
um produces what i think is some of the
highest quality analysis
uh both of the public and private
markets and also some structural
analysis as well so uh super excited to
talk to him today so thanks so much for
doing this
i appreciate you having me it's uh
you guys cannot see him but he's
literally sitting in a dark room and we
were joking before not only will he not
reveal his identity but it actually
looks like he's in witness protection so
uh let's start maybe with uh asset
allocation i think i know that you've
done a whole bunch of
uh work here around kind of the the
evolving 60 40 portfolio
kind of just maybe elaborate a little
bit there yeah absolutely
so when you think about asset allocation
a lot of this ultimately depends on
the type of investor group that you're
talking about right so
you bifurcate between retail high net
worth ultra high net worth
and downwards pensions foundations and
sovereigns and they have different
liquidity deeds and mandates
uh we probably get the most visibility
from pension plans
so if we start there i think it'll come
as no surprise to anybody that puts view
you know pension plans have a funding
crisis going on you know depending upon
your model or assumptions
the underfunded pension liability in the
u.s is expected to be anywhere between
one and a half to six trillion dollars
uh so you have to go about
you know thinking how do you try and
reduce that gas you need to either
contribute more pay less or generate
higher returns
uh first two clearly aren't that popular
someone chases the third
you know if we rewind the clock for a
second back to 1981
the 30-year u.s treasury peaked at 15
percent you know today that's 1.44
so if you think about how you derive
expected returns you sort of start with
that risk-free rate you had a risk
screening on top of that
so you know top pension funds over time
uh you know disclose what their assumed
annual returns were and what their
actual annual returns were
and back in the 1960s these guys were
all estimating four percent returns
which was roughly in line with the
10-year treasury at that time
you know that drifted to seven percent
in the 1980s which was actually a slight
discount to treasury yields
uh and the expected return has been
roughly flat ever since you know covered
in that seven to eight percent range
yeah well the 30 years gone from 15
percent to one and a half percent
so so that implies you've seen risk
premium expansion
significantly over that time period from
arguably negative
to one percent to six and a half percent
plus you know pushing these allocators
out the risk curve
so no surprise that's exactly what's
happened if you look at pension plan
allocation they've taken allocations to
alternative assets from roughly
seven percent in 1990 to 30 last year
uh you know they managed an estimated
four and a half trillion dollars of
assets so
that's roughly a trillion dollars that
had to get moved around between
those two different buckets right so
that's pretty significant
if you switch gears for a second towards
endowments
um there's 600 billion dollars of assets
held by endowments
and they saw an even bigger shift in uh
asset allocation you know taking
allocation to alternatives from six
percent 1990 to 53
last year you know dave swanson at yale
really pioneered what people call the
modern endowment model of the yale model
and it's based on a heavy alternative
asset allocation
while simultaneously avoiding asset
classes such as fixed income and
commodities
if you look at yale's annual disclosures
they actually won't even break out bonds
on a stand-alone basis
they they tie it in with cash and they
say bonds and cash are
less than seven percent um you know from
endowments you can kind of keep going
down
stream to sort of what i'll call like
the broader retail allocation
and if you start with ria's there's
roughly 10 to 12 trillion dollars in
investable assets with ras in the u.s
you have 7 trillion that sit at
wirehouse banks and another 3 trillion
that sit at what we'll call the regional
ras
yeah so while those pensions and
endowments might have a 30 to 60
allocation to alts if you're at a wire
house bank your allocation is somewhere
to the tune of 10 to 12 percent
you had a regional rra you're kind of in
that one to two percent range and the
difference isn't really sophistication
of financial advisors or a net worth of
clients
but it comes down to infrastructure
performance access which is why a lot of
those companies on the private side are
of interest to us
and then you know getting to your
question about that 60 40 portfolio
right i kind of consider that
you know 401k other retirement assets
do-it-yourself investors
my 60-40 portfolio has been you know
talked about for decades it was
popularized by jack vogel at vanguard
and for really good reason
that's had an outstanding track record
for the past 50 years it's
uh generated positive returns 82 percent
of the time
you know 93 percent over trailing three
year period 99 and a half percent over
trailing five year periods alone
exception was a great financial crisis
it's posted annual returns of 10 and a
half percent for 50 years so
you'd be hard-pressed to find any active
manager that can compete with that on a
pre-fee basis let alone post fees
uh and stocks were definitely a big
component of that but bonds were just as
important so they had an average return
of seven and a half percent over the
past 40 years
which all comes back to yield right so
the average 10 year during that time
period was 6.2
today at 65 basis points so you know in
this
new yield environment uh that 60 40
portfolio just
isn't going to generate the same returns
going forward you've had people like
warden professor jeremy siegel come out
and say 75 25 is the new 60 40.
i think that's probably too simplistic i
think you have to get smarter than that
and you know given the data available
depending upon your age your liquidity
needs your time to rise into retirement
i think you see a pivot towards you know
95 500
0 in this type of an interest rate
environment and when you talk about
30 trillion dollars of retirement assets
you know
5 trillion that fits in 401ks one and a
half trillion and system target date
retirement funds
you know that that's the potential for
another real significant
uh reallocation of assets
and so obviously there's not a kind of
one-size-fits-all which i think
previously people had
had kind of fallen uh victim to uh
when that shift occurs which really is
kind of already underway
what is the impact on the market side
right so where do you see that capital
going if that 60 goes to 75 90 you know
even 100
where does the capital go and then kind
of how do you see that uh changing the
market dynamics as well
yeah so a couple things there you know
first if we look at sort of the aum of
hedge funds vc firms and pe firms over
that time period they've clearly been
the biggest beneficiaries so
back in 1976 there was less than a
billion dollars allocated to hedge funds
in total
in 96 that was 130 billion today that's
a trillion dollars
right so those are really public market
and some public credit
uh investment opportunities for the most
part in 1976 there was less than four
billion dollars in venture capital
uh funding in 96 it was 39 billion today
that's approaching 500 billion right so
that starts to matriculate itself in the
private markets
and then you know probably most
impressively for pe firms there's less
than a billion dollars and 76
and 96 there's 160 billion and today
that's one and a half trillion
and they had two tailwinds right lower
interest rates
make lbos a lot more attractive they
also have the you know genesis
of the high-yield bond market by you
know milking and all the folks over at
drexel so you kind of had the birth of
an asset class concurrent with this
massive capital allocation chip so
you're seeing people going to private
equity you're seeing people going to
venture and you're seeing people call it
public markets
and what becomes interesting is at the
same time that you have these assets
flowing into the public markets the
number of public companies have been cut
in half
right so from 1996 to today you have
half the number of publicly traded
companies that you do
we're just at three quarters of where we
were in in 1974 so you have
greater assets chasing less and less
opportunities
there was a really good academic paper
published called the u.s
listing gap by folks out of i believe
cornell and ohio state
and they showed that back in 76 the the
market cap of u.s stocks was 3.3
trillion
which was you know 49 percent of gdp and
today it's 38 trillion which is
176 gdp right the average market cap of
a company was 650 million bucks back
then and today's 10 billion dollars
so yeah when you think about that it
naturally leads the price appreciation
because there's only so many places you
can allocate that capital
got it and so obviously um not only are
we seeing
um kind of this movement of capital but
uh this is all happening simultaneous to
a pandemic an economic recession kind of
all of the macro shifts that we've seen
how does um the uh kind of catalyst for
all of this
and then the reaction of lower interest
rates and a bunch of quantitative easing
how did that kind of perfect storm of um
events
change or accelerate um kind of this
shift
sure absolutely so you know what i've
said historically is
qe infinity kind of pushed people out
the risk curve right so it changed your
savings account into your checking
account the bond market into the savings
account the equity market the bond
markets the venture markets the equity
market
and it gave rise to the crypto market as
the new venture market
right and you're kind of seeing that
happen so you know in the 30 years
before the global financial crisis the
fed's balance sheet expanded by 700
billion dollars
uh that took 10 days in march right you
know we've injected seven trillion
dollars of liquidity into the system
year-to-date
uh with another trillion to two on the
way which is crazy when your bid ask is
now a trillion dollars
but it's not just the fed right so
cumulative central bank balance sheets
have exploded
so from 2000 to 2008 the balance sheets
of the fed the boj
the swiss national bank the boe and the
ecb went from two to four trillion
dollars
then post crisis it went from four to
ten this year alone we've gone from 16
to 22.
so basically eight months we saw as much
cumulative central bank balance sheet
extension as we did seven years post
not only the global financial crisis but
the euro crisis as well and three times
as much during the decade prior to
the postal.com crash right so you've
seen this
insane amount of liquidity uh that's
entered to the market and i think you
know in march it was really a seminal
moment where we crossed the rubicon
where no one asked how do we pay for
this
anymore right you know the fact that the
democrats and republicans
right now are arguing over one at two
trillion dollars
is asinine if you think about where we
were you know ten years ago
and i think that's really the big
difference today versus you know
our our father's qe generation right
where
a lot of people said oh inflation's
going to come inflation's going to come
but it never really materialized
i think you had a completely different
macro backdrop uh then versus now right
so prior to global financial
crisis banks had zero excess reserves
they were right against their limits
you know so when the fed started to
expand its balance sheet uh that went
into the excess reserves the bank said
the hell they never really materialized
in m1 and m2
uh this year you know you have money
going directly into checking accounts
with the stimulus check it looks like
we're going to have another one on the
way before the election
you have federal unemployment benefits
topping people up at greater than the
median salary in this country
you have money going directly to
companies with ppp and eidl
you have the fed literally backstopping
corporate bond purchases
so you're actually seeing a significant
increase in m2
so you know the fed publishes all this
data if you look at fred charts you can
look at a chart of m2 throughout the
totality of the global financial crisis
it's grown in a linear fashion up until
this year um
where it's up you know three trillion
dollars here a day you know to put that
in perspective
it took seven years to expand by three
trillion dollars that just happened in
four months
you know so in june which is the last
metric we have m2 is up 25
year over year that's the highest
reading all time the last time it
increased anywhere remotely close to the
space was during world war
ii so you think about the inflationary
pressures
that we have uh right now where does
money go
i know you've spoken about this letter a
lot on this podcast
paul theodore jones talks about you know
backing the fastest horse in this
race and he highlighted you know nasdaq
100 stocks bitcoin and gold and you know
he
he pointed to bitcoin there but i think
you're seeing that materialize not only
uh in the credit markets which have
gotten incredibly tight you know
therefore in the equity markets which
should rally now back to all-time highs
and of course in this long
tail of you know alternative assets
whether it be you know gold whether it
be bitcoin or whether it be private
markets
yeah and so i think one of the things
that uh becomes really interesting
is not only do you have some structural
differences that you just highlighted
but also the rhetoric around
inflation is changing right you now have
multiple people
uh throughout the federal reserve system
that are talking about uh
overshooting that two percent target and
potentially not even
taking any action to rein it in until we
hit two and a half or higher
um does that kind of change the analysis
or or give you more confidence that you
know we will see those higher levels of
inflation because they're literally
talking about it now as well
you know i think that helps right so i
guess just for for the listeners there's
still that vocal deflation camp right
that says monetary expansion alone isn't
sufficient enough to generate inflation
if you look at japan
that's still the poster child of debt
deflation right where monetary financing
is the deficits it's been
ineffective but i would point out since
1999 their m2 has never grown by more
than five percent per year right worry
for xn it's just
august you know there seems to be this
consensus out there that we're going to
have high unemployment and weak demand
which is going to lead to deflationary
pressures and that starts to have sort
of this you know downward demand
spiral uh which is a lot of
fear-mongering and it's going to cause
people to save and not
spend so i think you know positioning
this as an inflation trend is trying to
incentivize people to spend
and then there's also concerns about job
displacement right you know technology
inherently creates deflationary
pressures
uh but you know covid19 a lot of people
are talking about it it's just societal
accelerant you know
uh accelerating structural changes but
are those typical or structural what
does that do for the job market right so
that's sort of a deflation camp
i still fall in favor of the inflation
camp for what we just talked about but
also
you look at things like the savings rate
right in april it jumped up to 32.2
which is the highest assault time you
know prior to kova that number was never
higher than 17 percent it's come down a
bit since then but in june it's
still 19 you know checking accounts you
have brian moynihan from bamel talking
about checking account balances at
all-time highs
you think about some of these industries
that were closed right now whether it be
travel restaurants entertainment even
game plan right you know it's two to
three trillion dollars a year
spent annually that's pent up and
earnings are
are much better than expected for a lot
of these public companies right so
you have the fed messaging that they're
going to be okay overshooting because if
you think about
what our paths are to get out of this
money printing
the only way to really do it is to
inflate it away so they're trying to
guide the market that way
and then you have a bunch of
inflationary pressures that i think are
going to materialize over the next two
years
which goes to the benefit of you know
really tech stocks bitcoin and gold
i tend to think that you're on to
something there let's talk a little bit
about what the uh the potential
places people can go to there's
obviously a very interesting
uh dynamic playing out in the public and
private markets uh talk a little bit
about kind of um that the
framework that you use to evaluate
companies staying longer than private
markets and how that's playing out
yeah look i'd say you know up until
probably
25 years ago you didn't have as much
delineation between public and private
markets right
what happened as these fund sizes got
larger and as capital allocators got
more sophisticated
they started to put people in boxes so
you were my long short equity hedge fund
manager you were my macro hedge fund
manager you're my early stage venture
investor my growth stage venture
investor you're my buy out private
equity shop you're my mid-market private
equity shop
near my private credit fund you know 25
years ago investing was investing right
so
you know we kind of look at things
opportunistically in terms of where can
we expect to get the best risk
adjusted return on our capital and i
think in this market
uh it's always changing right in march
you saw some
really significant buying opportunities
in public markets that you really
haven't seen in the past decade and that
was
the bulk of our focus um and in march
and april you didn't see a
ton of early stage venture investing get
done
now you start to see that market heat up
like there's never been a problem which
is which is quite fascinating but
i also think about where you have
bubbles in different parts of the market
so
one of the beauties about early stage
investing on the venture side
and why we focus so much there is it's
really difficult to create a bubble in
that part of the market right no matter
how much capital
is in the ecosystem uh if you're raising
a pre-feed or seed round
unless you're jack dorsey going at it
for the third time you know
your valuation is going to be somewhere
between
you know four to five million to 10 to
12 million right you have those
occasional repeat founders that'll get
above
that but if someone's going to build a
unicorn a deck of corn or a generational
company
you know that's all a rounding error as
it pertains to sort of your return on
capital investment it's going to be more
important
whether or not you have the capital to
participate in those subsequent rounds
and avoid the dilution than anything
else so
yeah we continue to be really interested
in that part of the market
on the public market you've seen you
know a bifurcation of these
really cloud-based first land-based
stocks and
thematically they're starting to trade
as baskets which is really fascinating
to watch you know
you can always look at the internals of
the market to try and get
sentiment any given day and as people
look at
these coveted test results and
hospitalization results over time
you start to see land-based stocks
whether those be restaurants casinos
energy companies industrials
you know trade with the correlation of
one and those cloud stocks
whether they be sas companies you know
tmt more broadly
trade with a correlation of one even
though there are a lot of different
underlying drivers
behind that so what we're trying to do
is identify those best-in-class
companies that can continue to compound
over time
uh and buy them at attractive entry
prices right so
we got super into cloud stocks in march
and april when we were talking our early
stage portfolio companies
and you know heard some common themes
right everyone was looking to
cut costs and we'd say okay can you cut
data dog this is a big expense no i
can't cut that can you cut octa can you
cut twilio
no but i can stop paying my rent and i
can fire
25 of my workforce it's like okay well
we should be buying data dot octa twilio
aws and and you know azure for amazon
and microsoft because
you don't have a business without those
companies right now so
those companies that are mission
critical you know we wrote a post where
we called them central nervous
system stocks like those are things that
are interesting to us
and so um as you kind of think through
those walk me through how you guys think
about valuing evaluation metrics in an
environment where it became very obvious
that they were mission critical
yeah sure so i think it's always helpful
to kind of
again start the macro and dive down so
you know
if you think about the s p 500 you know
trading multiples over time have trended
gradually higher
no one's making a call on what 2020 eps
will be so we'll leave that aside for a
second but 2019
you're at 163 dollars a share and next
year street consensus is sort of
170 and a trump administration and 150
and a fight in administration and that
really depends upon corporate tax reform
so
you know at current levels you're
sitting between 20 to 22 times
next year's earning versus a three or
four year average of 19 to 20 times and
a 10-year average of 18 times so
you know people talk about how frothy
this market is
we're in line with recent averages which
is much more important than sort of that
60-year average of 15 and a half times
earnings because uh you know it's just a
different macro environment right so
part of this is due to the lower
interest rates which we've kind of
discussed at taxi
now but you can't look at equity
valuations without considering
uh what interest rates are right so you
have to look at that equity risk premium
in the 2010s it was actually
the highest equity risk premium on
record given those artificially low
interest rates and interest rates have
only gone lower
and it also has to do with you know the
capital that we talked about going into
that market
it's never been easier to index and
diversify right so diversification
across
500 stocks for the s p 500 or 2000
stocks for the russell 2000 with a
single click of a button
um you know that inherently supports
higher multiples because you're getting
a diversified basket without doing as
much work so very different
you know in the 70s and 80s and early
90s when you didn't have the
proliferation of these ets at lower no
cost
you know given from the technological
progress we've made you know margins
have been trending secretly higher
uh which i think is really important and
tech stocks have become the largest
constituent of the s p 500 so it's very
different than when
you know financials which are going to
trade anywhere from you know 0.75
to 1.25 book value and 8 to 12 times
earnings are the biggest component of
the s p 500
when you have tech stocks that are you
know trillion dollar market caps
compounding at 30
per year still just define all laws of
gravity
you know making out that so i think you
know multiples are trending secretly
higher and from there you kind of
dive into the sub sectors right so if we
look at these sas companies which
you know have really outperformed
bessemer is a pretty good emerging cloud
index
it's up 55 year-to-date versus the
nasdaq up 23
versus the s p up four and the dow
actually still down for
you know the markets bifurcated based on
a couple key
uh metrics that we look at you know
predominantly growth rates
and net dollar retention around dr right
so
we cure them into high mid and slow
growth based on what sort of
uh top you know quartiles are for for
these companies right now
and these high growth means are trading
25 to 30 times revenue and those mid
growth names are trading 14 to 16 times
and those low growth names are trading
eight to ten times
you know to put that in perspective last
year high growth names were probably 15
times
um you know those mid-growth names were
10 and the low growth were five
um so you've definitely seen multiple
expansion uh
which which makes us wary but the
results have been there right so
we look at uh what those e v to revenue
numbers
are versus its peer set versus itself
over time
we'll look at net dollar retention right
which is just that beginning of period
revenue plus upgrades less downgrades
less
churn over that beginning period revenue
i think that starts to show how sticky
that business
is for their clients so you know if you
look at some of these companies that had
120 130 percent 140
net dollar retentions those are the
companies that were up 100
plus year to date if you look at those
companies that were below 100 or
hovering in like that 95 to 105 those
were the companies that were up single
digits
uh which you know is still significant
in this market but the market was
clearly
getting smart that they showed that was
what was important right
what are people not going to cut you
know you have that classic rule of 40
for sas companies where you'll get
growth rate plus profit margin be great
40
right now everyone's there so people are
talking about the rule 60 the rule 70.
we'll see where it goes you know you're
still not coalescing around what profit
margin is as whether it's you know
ebitda x stock based comp or unlevered
free cash flow or cash from operations
but
you know that's something that we try
and keep an eye on and then you know for
our early stage companies we're always
looking at
revenue growth and sales efficiency and
customer retention and burn right and
cacked ltv and all sort of the common
ratios
uh and you can kind of do this for each
sub-sector of the market right so
for your tech companies you're you're
you know that are non-sas based your
latinate your eb to ebitda and your pe
multiples you get
sort of financial services depending
upon the sub sector you're looking at
some combination of
you know pe or price to book once you
start getting to the banks or dividend
yields
and you know your consumer discretion
your consumer staples your materials
your communications your utilities it's
all in that ev to ebitda or unlevered
free cash shield
and you know we're always comping
companies versus their peers today
versus ourselves over time and where the
broader market is
one of the things that somebody i
respect a lot was talking to me about
that i thought was really interesting is
they said look value investing has
historically been a great way to invest
the difference is that uh there's a lot
of people who uh
misunderstand how to determine value of
these technology stocks right that's
basically kind of what you're talking
about here of just like what are these
things actually worth we know what the
prices are but
what is that value um and so as you kind
of do this
how do you guys think about that
actually changing over time right so
you're talking a little bit about kind
of the the macro environment you're
talking a little bit
um about kind of uh the shift over the
number of years but
are there other things that you guys
look at from a factor standpoint
of how value can actually change um
to peer sets to themselves over time or
anything like that outside of just a
macro environment
yeah so you know why do people look at
valuation multiples to begin with
usually it's just a heuristic to try and
back into valuation
right what is the value of a company it
should theoretically be the discounted
value of the cash flows today
right so i think for some of these high
growth
sas companies that works out really well
right if you're willing to put in the
time to build about 20-year dcs and you
moderate these growth rates that are 150
200 year-over-year and you're able to
show that margin expansion that a lot of
them have shown over time
you know they don't look overvalued
today despite trading at
15 times revenue but most people don't
do that they say it trades at 15 times
revenue which is
asinine but it's funny because of the
margin potentials these companies have
right so
look at something like facebook which is
you know approaching a trillion dollar
market cap and it trades at 10 times
revenue which would seem crazy
but they have 50 even margins and 40 net
income margin so
you know it's not that crazy when they
trade at 30 times earnings when the s p
500 is trading at 22 times earnings
right so you can't look at any of this
stuff in a vacuum and i think that's
where
value investors really get caught up is
they're missing
the non-stationary aspect of financial
markets so
the best quant funds in the world are
the ones that are able to detect that
sort of instantaneously right
when are the market internals changing
and i think a lot of quant funds
struggle with that which is why he saw a
bunch of blow-ups in
march and april when it was sort of an
unprecedented time period but that's why
you see
the folks at renaissance just continue
to print money time over time because
they understand that non-stationary
element now won't pretend to understand
it at those micro speeds but
you know you have to understand that in
the context of what your entry points
are and be comfortable paying up over
time for companies that you think can
compound
and if you're buying up too much today
for the next 18 months but you think
you know these companies become critical
parts of software infrastructure
over time they will grow into those
valuations right there are plenty of
times where people bought apple or
people who bought amazon
people bought google or microsoft uh and
it was overvalued
uh versus where it should have been and
it disappointed for a period of time but
if you believe in those companies long
term you should kind of see what happens
yeah i want to throw out a couple of
names for you and uh just kind of let
you riff on them the first being
square which which has kind of become a
darling i think for many people
kind of how do you evaluate that yeah so
if you think about square they have two
significant ecosystems they're growing
right they have their salary ecosystem
they have cash app and
you know i think they're aiming for the
holy grail of payments which is this
closed loop payment system that cuts out
intermediaries so on the seller
ecosystem square notes there's 20
million businesses in the us with six
trillion of gross receipts which is an
85 billion dollar cam for them
they think they can get 39 billion
dollars of transactional profit 30
billion software
sales another 12 billion from uh square
capital and you know five
dollars from what they call other
financial services uh but cash app is
really this this hidden gem there which
was started in a hackathon internally
you know it's the second largest
peer-to-peer payment application digital
law in the u.s behind them oh even
though it had a much later start
and it allows for direct deposits you
know cash cards boost rewards equity
trade of course bitcoin trading
uh they think this is a 9 trillion
addressable market you know last quarter
they announced 30 million
monthly active users uh with more than 7
million spending on the card itself you
know the cash app generated 1.2 billion
dollars of revenue and
8 million of gross profit now a lot of
that was bitcoin and it's really
transactional notional volume but even
if you strip the bitcoin out of that
it's 325 million dollars of revenue
which is up 140
year-over-year and perhaps most
impressively they have 1.7 billion
dollars of cash deposits right so
you start getting in the realm of over a
billion dollar cash deposit banking i
put that in quotes below they've just
filed for their occ
charter you know that becomes a really
interesting company
jack was talking about moving to africa
for six months you know prior to all
things covet and twitter shareholders
were sort of up in arms about that
but thinking about sub-saharan africa
from a macro perspective
you know it's home to the world's
largest free trade area got the youngest
labor force in the world over the next
20 years it'll be home to the 10 fastest
growing cities in the world it's 1.2
billion people that
are undergoing their first real
urbanization genesis moment
and they've been dealing with mobile
money since 2007 when m-pesa first
launched it there
right so 20 years half the world's
population is going to be in africa
and i think fintech is going to be the
area that really accelerates that growth
so i think he's spot on in looking there
and i think
if square can replicate what they were
able to do
and you know quite frankly some more
rural parts of the u.s to start which is
where they started
i think that becomes such an interesting
point for them so
you know stocks up 140 year-to-date it's
got a 65 billion dollar market cap
versus seven billion dollars in
projected revenue 325 million of
dollars so you know there's no valuation
metric that justifies square's valuation
today
it's really this is a scarce asset in
fintech that has a ton of upside
optionality
and for me if i was a banker i'd be
pitching them on m a right now
right so i've written about this i know
you've spoken about it i think you know
combined square and twitter you have a
vertically integrated payment processor
with the twitter social media feed
integrating to message functionality you
can send
invest and spend money you really create
that wechat or alipay
of the west um i think you could do that
in an all stock transaction
and you know bankers are going to sit
there and look at the relative trading
ratio over different
periods of time and you know square's
never been more attractive relative to
twitter i think that's quite interesting
but
say they can't get over conflicts there
um
i think there's a lot they can do with
the currency today right so
at a 67 billion dollar market they can
go by discover financial service and
actually get into the car network game
directly right you know that's a 15
billion dollar market cap it had
eight billion dollars in revenue and
four billion dollars and even done three
billion dollars in net income
you know that becomes really interesting
for them but if they're really trying to
stick to that closed loop
network you know maybe they try and do
something to go after shopify's business
may acquire like the wicks out of 15
billion
anytime your currency is this uh
overvalued versus any metric you want to
be on the offensive and i think there's
a ton that they could do there
i think it's a scarce asset i think jack
has
really done a lot to innovate around the
core product
i think they went about building the
business from the right way starting
with deposits
and then expanding into this other
functionality so i think
there's a ton of optionality there which
is why it trades where it does because
people are just forced to own it
yeah to me that that's the whole thing
right is um the
idea of going after the deposits first
and not going after brokerage just is a
much more scalable bigger business that
can be built
uh it's got better margins and one thing
that's interesting to me kind of going
uh tangentially related to this is just
a lot of the financial service stocks uh
there's kind of this bifurcation between
things that trade like banks or things
that trade like fintech companies right
i think squares will be able to kind of
navigate itself very nicely obviously
into the the fintech space
uh because that they've been you know
not the position that they're in and not
a position of strength if they were to
trade like any old bank stock right
for sure yeah uh next name is uh
lemonade uh
this one is uh is that they confusing a
lot of people
yeah oh consider me confused right uh
i i don't i don't want to pretend to be
an expert on it but you know you're
talking about three and a half billion
dollars in market cap for
67 million dollars in revenue and 109
million dollars in net losses
compared to 116 million in gross written
premium
that math just doesn't add up right like
b2c insurance is hard
you know in their s1 they said their
gross loss ratio was 161
and now it's down to 80 percent you know
but their
net loss per dollar of gross written
premium went from 312 to 94
so they're losing 94 cents for every
dollar gross written premium
like math doesn't work they're going to
need to raise more capital
um like they do not have enough cash on
their balance sheet to continue to run
this
doesn't he said as much i don't usually
give credit to self-site analysts but uh
he terry over at goldman initiated
coverage on lemonade at sale and he said
you know it's essentially venture
investing in public markets and you know
he said that they're gonna have five
years of operating losses before
breaking even you know mention that
they're gonna need more cash
uh i think there's a retail bid for
these type of assets because they can't
get into venture
and it seems like early stage venture
but there are a lot of names i would own
before i touch this because insurance is
hard and they try and play up this data
angle
you know insurers have more data than
anybody and they've been collecting it
for hundreds of years and
they do not have you know 94 spents per
dollar of gross written premium and net
losses right that's just a difficult
business
scale when i read the s1 uh it cracked
me up because uh
you're saying this whole idea of like a
startup but in the public markets uh
there was a lot of the like buzzwords
you know artificial intelligence oh yeah
i mean it was littered throughout it and
uh someone you can see why
if you don't look at startup decks all
day long like okay this sounds you know
super sexy and
kind of technology enabled but i think
also the second thing
that's really interesting is uh similar
to in the finance
service side um there's old school
insurance companies that traded a
certain
kind of multiple and then you get into
these more kind of technology-enabled
companies they're getting these
outrageous valuations
and uh what it appears is going to
happen is all the old-school guys are
going to now either go
m a or they're going to try to start
convincing the market that no actually
we have technology right in whatever
form after they do that like that seems
to be the only way that they can kind of
compete
right i i'm very bullish in sure tech as
a sub sector of fintech when it's
enabling technology for incumbent
insurance providers right the insurance
game is all about balance sheet and it's
all about
scale and and that's what makes b2c
models incredibly difficult because you
don't have that insured base to pull the
risk off of right which is why you're
seeing
these uh loss ratios so uh i i think
there's a huge opportunity for the tech
enablers
it's still an industry that's dominated
by pen and paper and you have all these
you know different organizations that
don't have that cross-organizational
reconciliation so
i think there's a huge need for startups
i'm just not convinced that b2c insurers
for
you know home insurance and property
insurance at least not at you know 100
million times
uh revenue makes sense uh
zoom has gone on uh an epic run here and
i think that uh
everyone uh has zoom fatigue everyone is
using it
um and it seems like they've kind of
been the winner that's pulled an entire
sector
um up but uh how do you evaluate that
business and
the kind of that vertical yeah sure so
zoom's gotten into verb territory
right which is always an enviable place
to be in um and i think that
speaks to sort of scarcity value uh you
know collaboration software has become a
critical component of the tech stack
right especially over the past
uh six months now um they quote a net
dollar retention figure of 130 percent
which puts them in the top decile uh my
concern with that is i don't know
if that's uh structurally high
or if it's cyclically high given the
environment that we're in right you know
you have a lot of people that talk about
some of the privacy concerns and
you know some of the large banks are
using microsoft teams and microsoft is
trying to crossfill that with azure
which is becoming a stickier and
stickier product particularly within
financial services
you obviously have google hangouts so
when you're competing with google and
microsoft and anything i
have paused but then again yeah
microsoft acquired skype and skype
should have been zoomed before zoom so
zoom clearly won there you know it's a
75 billion dollar market cap trading
north of 50 times run rate sales so
even though revenue is growing you know
at astronomical rates north 150
year over year you have a ways to go to
grow into that valuation i think
this is sort of the quintessential stock
that traded as part of what i call a
coveted basket right you had
zoom you had telethon you had moderna
you had
you know any of these other sort of work
from home stocks that got caught up in
that
um and it will continue to trade with
high correlation in there
um i think it's a name you could trade i
think it's hard to own for the long run
here at that valuation but if you have
it earlier you know there's no reason to
cut it
i always think about the uh like
millennial uh
stock basket which is you know not even
all stocks like the bitcoin the tesla's
whatever
and then i think of like the boomer pack
and the boomer pack is exactly some of
the companies you just described right
where they're like
do digital stuff right like get excited
about it
uh speaking of tesla uh what are
thoughts there
yeah so i i wrote a piece entitled you
know invest in what you know what does
democratization of equity investing mean
for valuation and performance
and it's it was a really poor attempt at
trying to
describe how these staff could trade it
you know these valuations and
if you look at the most frequently
traded names on robin hood or fractional
equity aggregators like an apex or
drivewell
or anyone else that reports these
metrics you know it's the same
names it's tesla it's apple it's
facebook it's google it's amazon
um and and if those names continue to be
owned by everybody there's sort of a
persistent bid
in the market now what's interesting
about tesla and why i think it has this
upward bias is because it's actually not
an index today
right so when you start talking about
micro inter market internals excuse me
you know tesla reported it's four
straight piles of quarter net income so
it's going to be added to the s p 500
probably at some point before year and
the way it works is you have to have a
company removed
right now there's a few m a deals on the
tape uh
tiffany's is probably uh the next one to
drop out if that deal closes which is
kind of
uh mid-september business so that that
could be when
when when tesla gets dead into the s p
500 it's going to be the single
largest ad of all time with something
like 60 billion dollars to buy right it
depends upon what the price is at that
point in time
um so what is mind blowing to me about
tesla is revenue is up mid single digits
year over year
you know but the stocks up whatever 4x
uh it's trading at a 350 billion dollar
market gap which is 13 times
trailing revenue and 10 times forward
revenue and it's not profitable
so you're really making a bet on elon
and over time that it could become this
software slash battery play
which you know he's shown the ability to
continue to innovate i think
the tesla bears of two or three years
ago
were right to be skeptical in that tesla
was not profitable there was not a path
to
profitability and you needed to continue
to raise capital to fund this business
and there was questions of whether or
not capital markets would be there
right there were a couple of those
really scary converts that barely got
done they had to do follow-on offerings
and
you know when tesla did solar city
everybody was up in arms
uh there will not be a question of
whether or not tesla can raise capital
anytime soon they can announce a massive
secondary tomorrow it'd probably be down
like two percent you'd be fine
um so i i think it it becomes a
stock in and of itself giving people's
perception of it and
you know on a retail basis what's
interesting is once it gets
added to the s p 500 most people think
that's a great thing you have all these
indexes that
have to own it then it starts to trade
with a much higher correlation to the
rest of the market
right so the market has these down days
you have these index funds that have to
continue to rebound
and i think it starts to act more like a
350 billion dollar stock would act and
not be gapping 10 20 30 40
uh month over month so it's interesting
there's definitely you know i don't want
to ever bet against people like elon
i but for me it's definitely one you
could trade it's difficult to own unless
you have a stomach for
you know 50 to 70 drawdowns like we saw
in march and if you do
you know god bless yeah one of the
things i've been thinking about and i i
don't have a good uh perspective on this
so i'd love to hear your idea
is um you mentioned earlier that kind of
venture capital has become the equity
markets right and kind of that this
shift in
risk uh what that does is it now brings
entrepreneurs who are used to a more
venture capital fueled uh
company building exercise and also
investors who understand this stuff so
if you look at for example in march
one of the things that was very obvious
very quickly was uh most companies in
the private markets that are
venture-backed are used to losing money
and so if all of a sudden you go to
revenue zero like if you had
capital on the balance sheet because
that's what you were expecting anyways
maybe your runway got cut shorter but
you still kind of were in the mode of
being able to
to operate in what i'll call kind of a
pandemic proof way right whatever the
hell that means
um but but how do you think about um
the way that these companies are funded
and the way that entrepreneurs raise
capital in the public markets if there
are more and more of these folks who
kind of have come up building these
businesses through venture capital
funding
yeah it's a really good question it's
something that you know we've thought
about quite a bit in terms of
are there different funding mechanisms
structurally for
public companies that could be of
interest right so for some of these
super high growth sas companies
where you have really sticky customers
and you have net dollar retention north
of like 130
you know can we systematically do
revenue shares where you're not taking
dilutive equity but you're able to grow
faster as opposed to sort of discount
your annual sas contract at 20
right that becomes interesting uh for
these companies that continue to lose
money i think it depends upon
uh the path to profitability right so
someone like square is very different
than someone like lemonade
right where lemonade you know what the
tried and true path the profitability is
for a insurer uh and it's not losing 94
cents from the dollar
right and it's not going from 312 to 94
cents like that's a very difficult path
i'm not sure what public market appetite
will be for continual financing for
something like square
if jack had to go to market for a
secondary i think people
understand that holy grail of sort of a
closed loop payment ecosystem
i mean just look at visa and mastercard
those are two of the best businesses in
the world since visa went public in
05 at the ebitda margins went from 20 to
70 percent its net income margins went
from 10 percent to 50
right they're literally
a global tax on payments you know
anytime somebody pays money anywhere
they're making money which is terrific
and i think people can see that and
square so so much of it i think is
business model dependent and industry
defendant
i think there's a couple of these long
only fund complexes with heroes the
fidelities of the world
that are playing in both the public and
private markets and therefore
uh you have those crossover pms that
will continue to fund them
you have the hedge funds like a tiger or
co2 that do the same
um so i think there is funding there um
i think you have to justify and i think
you have to be you know pretty
transparent with forward guidance
and you have to play the game with the
indices and the exchanges on a
listing requirement basis right so
there's a lot of hoops you have to jump
through but i think
it could definitely be more common it
also depends upon
at what point your life cycle you go
public right you look at uber and lyft
they were able to raise insatiable
amounts of capital privately and
everybody thought it was going to
be continued up to the right no one
could have predicted covet and what that
would do for
ride sharing or transportation but
because those businesses are so capital
intensive and haven't really
proven out the unit of economics for
that to work like
they're going to be challenged a lot
more than say you know a company like
marquette in the fintech space if they
decide to go public tomorrow needed to
raise more capital you know i think
they'd be capital behind
yeah uh amazon is another one that i
think is uh
uh very misunderstood for a long period
of time uh and now all of a sudden has
become you know
the company uh how do you guys kind of
evaluate that one
yeah so you know amazon for us is really
the aws story right
it's a 43 billion dollars in run rate
revenue you know azure's at 25 billion
uh they added three and a half billion
in revenue during the first half of this
year they have
you know aws itself has 30 operating
margins compared to the rest of the
business at three percent for north
american
zero for international right so it is
the cash cow of amazon
nobody has the time horizon of jeff
bezos except for
maybe zuckerberg right and no but no one
has the goodwill of the public markets
that bezos has
which i think is really important
building the business that he's built
being able to systematically expand the
new product categories you know fail
like he's failed plenty of times and
continue to succeed
i mean the first mention of uh the cloud
i think they called it
amazon elastic cloud compute a ecc
back in probably 2003 or 2005 they had
it in their 10k for the first time
and you'd see two or three mentions and
i don't think they broke it out until
2012 or 2013
as an actual segment and then over the
past five years you've seen astronomical
growth
we are in such the early innings of the
migration to the cloud
uh financial service and legal
industries are still
so on-prem if you have startups that
sell into them you're kind of mind-blown
every time you say wait you have to go
install this on-prem now they don't even
have people in their office but
they can't you know put software in the
cloud it's crazy
so i think that becomes really
interesting what they've built in this
mode around
prime being a loss leader for all these
other verticals becomes incredibly
important
um they have a senior leadership team
that has a lot of continuity which i
also think is critical right so
uh for a lot of these founder-run
companies you sort of have that key
man or woman risk and you saw it with
you know apple when steve jobs passed
away people today are still doubting tim
cook despite the performance of that
factions jobs pass
[Music]
with amazon you have senior leaders that
have been there for 20 years and they
really all
preach the same discipline i think
that's very very difficult to ingrain in
the company particularly a company
that's been along that well
so you know it's one of uh monopoly or
duopoly in so many different areas and
those are the best businesses to own so
while it screams rich at so many
different points in time it's just the
scarcity value of an asset whether it be
transportation and logistics aws so that
you know core north america merchant
business
where prime itself can just get spun out
there's a ton of optionality there and
you know
we like quite dependent yeah one of the
things that's very obvious is
uh bezos over the years took all the
cost centers turned them into these
profit centers and
um has built very very large businesses
with great margins in some cases
do you guys see either through
regulatory pressure or
from a business case uh actually going
ahead and spitting some of these off as
individual kind of companies what is now
today just a line item or a product
yeah i think part of it's going to
depend upon what happens in november
right i think it's
hard to make the case that amazon is
doing anything that's anti-consumer
though
right so we're gonna have to change
antitrust laws which we haven't been
able to do in 60 years here and we
probably
should right but i think i think that
becomes pretty difficult like if they
spun off aws into its own business it'd
be one of the most valuable companies in
the world and you know they could enter
into a preferred relationship with them
and they could do that
um anything else i just think would be
too problematic yeah
facebook is a little bit different in
terms of like
if they were forced to spin up whatsapp
or
instagram because of data privacy
concerns or you know as they get into
facebook financial services
they're like we don't want the largest
country in the world to have their own
you know sovereign monetary unit um i
think that some of the parts story is
actually more
interesting at facebook than it is at an
amazon where
you know both those properties could
have much more stronger embedded finance
place standalone right
instagram on the e-commerce side
whatsapp on the payment side
ad brokerage functionality ad cash
deposit functionality you can't do that
within
the umbrella that is facebook given its
size and scale so
i think that in a force breakup becomes
interesting amazon i think you get to
what's the point right you know
and during the pandemic how many people
were just relying on amazon prime
packages coming to their door
you know you need that scale to deliver
that service
um i think the regulators would have a
tough time arguing that case in court if
they were forced to
i always laugh at the the joke in new
york city is that every apartment
buildings lobby looks like an amazon
warehouse during the holidays
right every time or during the totality
of the pandemic
absolutely uh one of the ways that uh
companies are
uh starting to get into the public
markets um especially when it's so
frothy right now
is uh using specs so we've seen kind of
direct listings and space become more
popular
uh how are you guys looking at uh maybe
specs specifically but even direct
listings
sure so you know we spent a lot of time
looking at stacks over the years and
sort of the
original formation of specs they were
really viewed as a payment scheme for
third tier
private equity firms right so they had a
very negative stigma on them
sponsors would put up risk capital four
to five percent in exchange for twenty
percent of the post ipo shares plus
penny warrants which entitlements are
usually another ten percent
um they'd buy kind of beat up private
companies and take them public and milk
those fees for what it was and try and
sell it over time to another company or
raise another stack
and that was the case in the the early
2000s late 90s
you had uh all-time high stack raises
in sort of the 0.607 time period
you started to see a little bit higher
quality sponsors
but the same type of targets where it
never really got people going
then in you know it was dead for three
years there was no appetite for stack
funding
uh you saw a little bit of a resurgence
in 2014 2015 and for the first time you
had some really high quality sponsors
you know people like martin franklin who
rolled up jardin
he did platform specialty nomad foods
and
i think that got the hedge fund
community interested uh
and then what happened last year which i
think was really sort of
the transitional moment was when chemoth
went after virgin and when draftking
went
public right those were two companies
that would have had a path to go public
you know chamos that has his reputation
publicly i know you've had him on the
podcast before
um and while both of those are
incredibly overvalued on
any traditional evaluation pastor it
showed there was a path and people
started to say
okay why are they doing that and i think
what really changed if you think about
mechanically how specs work you're the
sponsor
they raise a pool of capital goes into a
trust uh it stays into that trust until
they announce an acquisition
shareholders vote on that acquisition if
it goes through great you know capitals
transfer that becomes an operating
company
if they voted down their capitals
returned right so it's really a lock box
fund
so the biggest buyers of spax day one
are merger arb
funds because they view it as an
alternative to a cash carry every once
in a while you get some long-homeless in
there
and their view is i buy this at 10 i
have a free put at 10 i get my warrants
and if they announce a deal anytime in
the next 12 to 18 months and this
cops to 10.50 to 11 a share
uh i can kind of sell that out at a five
to ten percent irr which is
in line with some of the safer spreads
and given the fact that you have that
better put in there
they don't mind putting capital to work
historically you had a big gap in
ownership from
the art funds who bought it at the ipo
to the transition to
long short hedge funds and long only
asset managers who had to own it after
right because deal gets announced the
arb fund fell down
there was no buyer in that middle part
uh that changed to this year when you
know you have the robin hood mafia as we
refer to it as just buy out those specs
in that transitory period they look at
things like nikola and
shell and fisker and you know bought
those stocks hand over fists and they
became top 50 owned
you know companies on uh robinhood which
is pretty wild to think about
and structurally you can't short a stack
right so prime brokers
can't re-hypothecate shares when it's in
that stack period until it transitions
to an operating company
so the only only sellers are those
people that are on the lease who
were selling previously or people who
are inherently long so i think as you
look at those dynamics people said okay
what's going on here and they got
smarter and the headline numbers are
crazy right 74 stack offerings this year
over 28 billion dollars which is 40
of the ipo market but if you look at
stacks versus
what they you know what you could do in
a direct listing or ipo
you have a lot of benefits so so on the
stack side you do have greater speed to
closing versus an ipo or direct listing
uh like a typical lemonade process you
can kind of get things done in three
months once you come to that
price point uh you have valuation
certainty
right which you don't have in an ipo or
direct listing so i know you know bill
gurley's been incredibly public about
sort of his opposition to
you know what he thinks to be systematic
under pricing of ipos
you you don't have that here in a direct
listing
you get a little bit better price
discovery but you don't have that price
certainty which i think is important
you know you have the management
continuity which you don't have in a
private equity sale
you have a lot of you have a lot more
flexibility in terms of the structure of
the deal
right how you can kind of incentivize
management with some of these warrants
which aren't afforded to people in ipo
or direct listing
uh usually you get the strategic
benefits of the sponsor
right you know you're now public fee of
the currency to do deals
and you have really this this quasi
permanent capital vehicle right so
i think it becomes quite interesting and
i think now that you've seen
some folks that weren't using it as a
funding resource of blast resort it's
starting to get
a lot more interest from both bankers
sponsors and venture funds and that's
why you've seen
you know all the above raised vehicles i
think what ackman did was also a pretty
seminal moment right
he took away that sponsor promote he
took away
you know the magnitude of the war and
overhang goldman has since advised on a
couple deals they've brought down that
warrant overhang
so i think given the sheer amount of
capital that's chasing deals
in the static world right now the
sponsors have to become more
economically incentivized and aligned
with
management team founders and investors
and now you're getting you know stack
3.0 which are cleaner structures that
offer a mechanism through which people
to go public
um so i i think it's interesting i don't
think it should be kind of brushed aside
it's just like the next crazy fad
because it's been a
capital markets mechanism that's been
around for 30 years it's just been
you know misused and abused in different
ways yeah i think what's really
interesting is
um when you talk about kind of 0708 and
before that just
the the um negative connotation or kind
of negative viewpoint people had
mainly was because the structure was so
ridiculous right and that was
misalignment between the sponsor and and
the company
i think now as you get kind of higher
tier or or more respected people coming
in doing it like the yakmens etc
uh you're seeing those economics change
i think people warm up to the idea that
oh wait there is way more alignment here
and this could be a vehicle moving
forward right it seems like
those two things are kind of happening
simultaneously um
and really it's just you know higher
quality people coming into the market
and if you think about like venture
growth companies that we just spoke
about in your question of whether or not
they can go public and continue to raise
capital
when you go via an ipo or direct listing
you cannot give forward-looking guidance
you can with a stack deal right which is
why you're seeing all these eev
companies
besides the fact that they're getting
bit up crazy and know nikola doesn't
have a doll in sales and it's worth 30
billion dollars but
um you know you can give pro forma
guidance for some of those story stocks
i think that's important you have your
time to message to the street right you
have three plus months of trading before
you convert to an operating company
you're not kind of rushed together in
that
two-week road show where the pre-road
show tests the water saves which i also
think is an important differentiator
um you have a a very unique and thorough
view of many markets assets
and uh in kind of valuation metrics
which brings us to uh kind of the world
series of finance right now which is
bitcoin
there is uh somebody uh in the financial
media who told me
that they could bring 10 people uh that
are the most respected financial
managers in the world
put them in a room uh say discuss
bitcoin and come back in an hour
and five will be on one side as bulls
five will be on uh the other side is
bears
but they literally will think the other
side is idiots for believing whichever
side they don't believe
so it's very controversial and kind of
debated
what's kind of your viewpoint on it and
how do you just think through
both the asset itself and then the
valuation
yeah it's funny i think
it's becoming seemingly a little bit
less
polarized than it was even two years ago
three years ago and definitely five
years ago where
i think now the sides will agree to
disagree but won't say the other people
are idiots whereas even just like 12 to
24 months ago that was the case right
and whether that's renaissance adding it
to their adv
or paul coming out publicly you know
saying that they put two percent
uh of the fund in it or you know
fidelity and some of these other
institutional
uh you know platforms that are starting
to offer it in different ways i think
that helps
i think you know the craziest thing is
bitcoin as a percent of gold is still
sitting
you know at like two percent right and
bitcoin as a percent of store value gold
might be three and a half percent four
percent you know we can argue how much
gold is store value versus actual you
know practical implications
um i think you know you've had travis on
your podcast a couple of times and i
think
he really says it best when he calls
bitcoin a non-sovereign hardcap supply
global immutable decentralized digital
store value right
and i think that's exactly what it is
and i think when you talk about
the sheer amount of balance sheet
expansion
quantitative easing that we've seen
globally you know risk for inflation you
sort of need this
sovereign grade resistant you know
non-sovereign store of value
if you think about gold it has some of
those properties you know we can
check with tyler and cameron and davey
day trader whether or not elon's going
to be mining it from asteroids or not
but
you know it does have a quasi-fix supply
although bitcoin stock to flow is going
to flip gold's next year so it's going
to be even more scarce given the fact
that we've just had
uh the having it has its own slew of
micro catalysts for bitcoin specific
which is why i like it you know over
gold here
uh it's a lot smaller you're seeing this
generational wealth transition
from you know boomers to millennials and
gen z who have shown a propensity to
favor it
you know tom lee over at fun struts done
a lot of really good work
uh on that you're starting to see
increased institutional access points in
adoption whether it's fidelity you know
offering up to riaa platforms whether
it's backed you know seeing record highs
or cme seeing record highs
you and i were talking before we got on
about some of the private wealth
divisions at some of the bulge bracket
banks talking about this
you got the recent guidance from the occ
saying chartered banks can custody
digital assets right
once you start to see that institutional
adoption you know the story really
becomes well
what is it and if you think it's an
alternative store value what's that
worth
right well you know there's trillions of
dollars held offshore in swiss bank
accounts for certain reasons right
there's
trillions of dollars held in gold and
are in sports teams
right there there's a ton of capital
that's held in these assets that are
perceived to be store values
why not a fixed supply sovereign lists
you know global money that's portable
and divisible and has all the properties
of store value you know incremental to
that of gold so
uh you know quite bullish on it i think
if you look at over time you know
we put a piece out showing uh bitcoin
around halvings how it acts on an annual
basis
right so the year of the having tends to
be pretty good up 100 to 150 percent
it's really that year after where you've
seen the biggest growth periods that was
2013 and 2017 i think
that's a bit of a normalization of
supply demand between miners that were
sitting on excess inventory that they
had to sell down it's a bit of a story
getting out there
and i think you could have never asked
for a better macro backdrop
for bitcoin to succeed right we could
debate about how good the macro backdrop
is for everything else
but if you're a bitcoin bull proponent i
think uh
that becomes uh really interesting so as
you look at
just even assets to hedge against which
sort of potential macro headwinds that
we're talking about
you know tech staff can continue to
outperform but at some point
you know they're bound to the gravity
evaluations and they're going to be
measured on
cash flows this becomes a real scarcity
game um
and with china trying to usurp the us
dollar is a global reserve currency and
a lot of you know sort of
uh our monetary enemies if you will
pissed at what the fed did with these
central bank lines during march and
april for all these people that are
short dollars
you need to start to look at
alternatives and alternatives aren't
these central bank digital currencies
which
are just the same thing subject to the
same inflation risk
just natively digital so they can move
around faster
alternatives have to be separate from uh
states and countries
and that's why i think bitcoin is so
unique even within sort of the
cryptocurrency world and a lot of the
people say oh the first one doesn't win
what about myspace or alta vista
i don't think that's true with money and
i definitely don't think that's true
here because
none of these other cryptocurrencies can
replicate the bitcoin origin story which
i think is so critical to the value
proposition right
anonymous founder anyone had the
opportunity to mine it there's no
pre-sale so when people start talking
about
you know some of these stable coin
projects whether it was basis or maker
or the next one that was supposed to use
to serve bitcoin i
always said i don't think andreessen or
polychain or
you know paradigm or anyone is going to
own 15 of the next global reserve
currency right just not going to happen
um and i think that uniqueness uh the
longer we go
you know the longer it stays true so uh
incredibly bullish i think you could
start to see
it make a real dent as that percent of
gold over time and especially as macro
fund starts to trade it right
seeing a firm like renaissance add this
is big that's very different
than a james street or drw
or vert 2 which are market makers by
nature right you know there's an
arbitrage opportunity they're going to
take that and
we know in 2017 2018 and today there are
a ton of arbitrage opportunities given
the fragmented nature of it
that's not what renaissance is doing
renaissance very likely has this in a
pool of you know a macro asset
and how frequent they're trading it is
one thing but i think you know you start
to see that you start to see people like
paul they get discretionary
you know mike novogratz and galaxy
partnering with case to try and get it
to riaa's fidelity
you know launching their product i think
i think it's really interesting right
now yeah and so obviously uh we see very
eye-to-eye i think on
a lot of what you just said and uh i
can't you know
state enough the macro environment just
being this like rocket fuel for
what normally happens around the the uh
havings and um
you know to me it's just a thing where
uh the having was already gonna happen
all of the analysis you guys did is
pretty spot on then you added that macro
backdrop and it's like
you know do we see another blow off top
next year probably at some point um just
given that the retail demand but
all of this is happening without the
institutions right or very few
institutions coming in
and so you know i uh go back to like two
three four percent whatever the gold
market cap is that the bitcoin's
captured
uh that's pretty much retail and so what
happens when these big guys do come in
right a 200 billion dollar asset you
know i keep trying to remind people like
there are asset managers in the world
that have more assets than that
right so like the market cap is so small
um
and so kind of how do you think about
the balance between let's
let's go first with bitcoin and gold's
market cap is this a thing where
um it's kind of a zero-sum game and
you'll actually see gold's market cap
drop as bitcoins rises
is it an expansionary thing where you'll
just get kind of two very large market
caps
uh and then timeline wise how do you
think about uh bitcoin's
uh market cap growing in comparison to
gold's market capital if i'll say next
ten years or so
sure so i definitely don't think it's
one or the other right you've seen both
rally year to date i think you continue
to see both rally given this macro
backdrop as much as you know we like to
think bitcoin's ready for prime time
it's still not ready for prime time in
terms of institutional adoption
but all those concerns we had about
inflation and sort of central bank
easing and sort of debasement of fiat
currency hold true
so whether you're institutional asset
managers pension funds sovereigns
or central banks you need to own gold
right and i think that's one of the big
things that people forget about is
central banks are some of the biggest
buyers and holders of gold in the world
which is
you know unique and differentiated
versus bitcoin today so
until that happens i think it'll be
tough to equal or surpass gold
um so i think rising tide lifts all
boats i think bitcoin will start to
meaningfully
dent into that because of how small it
is right just while large numbers it's
going to be a lot easier to grow a 200
billion dollar asset than it is to nine
trillion dollar asset
and there's a lot less capital there
right like gold if you look at sort of
ownership and the number of holders of
the etfs and physical it's at all-time
highs right so i think
uh bitcoin is a lot cleaner from a
positioning standpoint
it remains under owned um you know
real vision had their summit a couple of
weeks ago and i think it might have been
oh said you know if you don't own
bitcoin you're effectively short of call
option
right and for those people that
understand option markets and that point
you're short gamma as it goes up you
have to buy more and more and more
and more and i think that starts to
happen with
uh these institutional managers who
don't own it within a portfolio so i
think that becomes interesting i think
over the next 10 years you could start
to
meaningfully infect uh you know inflect
on that i think 25 50
of gold's uh theoretical store of value
tam could be
dented by bitcoin um and i think it just
continues to become part of that asset
allocation which we started with up top
right as institutional investors
allocate to alt
this falls within that alternative
sleeve and whether it's direct whether
it's through a fund
you'll start to have look through
exposure there i think it also ties back
to what we talked about with tesla and
apple right
as all these fintech firms globally
aggregate assets in china and are
forcing people to invest for the first
time
uh you have your disney staff next to
your bitcoin and in my opinion next year
you know michael jordan rookie card and
everything else right there is sort of
your
holistic portfolio and i think bitcoin
is is a critical
uh portion of that which will also have
a bid and then you talk about the
generational wealth transition over the
next 10 years you're going to see
you know several trillion dollars
migrate from boomers to millennial and
gen z which is only going to continue
over the next 20 years and i think you
start to get that reallocation as well
yeah i i don't know how exactly the
transition happens and obviously that's
what we're trying to figure out and
that's we're deploying capital but it
feels like the
the end game here is every stock bond
currency and commodity is digitized
uh which empowers that ability to kind
of hold them all in the same place and
and
technology stack is you know very
similar if not identical and then what
you get is you just get differentiation
of the actual asset so
what's the difference between holding a
digital stock certificate versus a
digital currency versus you know
whatever the next digital asset is
they're all pretty much the same it's
just you're getting exposure to the
actual asset itself
um that's different uh and and so in
that uh
vein how do you think about the actual
usage of bitcoin today right so one of
the things that um that the metric that
stands out my mind
is um if i remember correctly it's the
adjusted on-chain transaction volume
is greater on an annual basis than the
transaction volume inside of like a
venmo
paypal uh apple pay whatever it is do
you
buy that as important statistics or is
that the stuff that is kind of more
cherry picking and confirmation bias
look i it's important in the sense that
it's happening it's occurring
and there haven't been any flaws bugs
stuffed you know from that right
there's obviously been hack separating
this thing um i think the difficult part
in that metric is we don't know what
that
really is calculated using right i know
the coinmetrics guys have done a really
good job cleansing that but how much of
that is
me buying something on chain
transferring it to myself off train or
you know moving different uh bitcoin
from
different cold storage solutions or uh
you know how much of it is actual use
case versus what we know what demo and
paypal are being used for within that
closed loop ecosystem so i think it's a
little bit apples to oranges
but i think it's important in terms of
like look you're talking about trillions
of dollars of year being processed on
this network
and it continues to work without a
glitch right which is the most important
thing in my mind
um and as you get those to be bigger and
larger size transactions
uh you know the the safety and security
of that network
starts to become confirmed right so you
know we had the
public company last week deployed 250
million dollars
treasury and what was probably only
seven days you know
and like you start to see stuff like
that you know that that size would have
been unfathomable in 2017 right you
would have taken bitcoin up
you know 50 in a week doing that and it
didn't move it was up five or six
percent
maybe maybe that's negative for
near-term positioning i don't know
but um i i think that's more relevant
than you know trying to compare and say
you know it's better and i also as you
think about that store value narrative
you know how much is gold used any given
day i don't think we need to get into
the whole medium exchange payment
mechanism uh for this to start to
you know materially appreciate from here
i think it's an upside that
uh covet is starting to force people
into in america
right this is already you know happening
all over in asia and even in parts of
africa
use qr codes at the point of payment uh
increased adoption of nfc technology
if you start to see qr codes at the
point of payment more you know maybe
start to see some of these bitcoin
wallets be
used but i i think people don't want to
spend it right now which is the most
important thing i think what becomes
more relevant is doing things like
paying dollars receive bitcoin right
like if you had a venmo and you owed me
25 bucks and i could say every time i
get a demo i just want to receive
bitcoin or square cash like
that becomes more interesting for me
right if that starts to be indicative of
the transaction volume you know
it's just so tough to buy what people
are actually using it for
um you uh i know you've looked at uh
block five before and uh one of the
things that is really interesting about
that business to me
uh is the fact that one they uh are
gonna come up with this credit card that
pays in bitcoin rewards
right so yeah kind of similar uh and
then the second thing is that they do
these flex payments so if you're earning
interest for example you can basically
choose your currency so you can take a
bitcoin
or digital dollar or whatever uh i i
don't think that there's an appetite yet
in the venmo's the you know paypal's
whatever
but i agree with you that the second you
start
really shifting the mindset of like wait
a second there's multiple currencies
that we support and do you want to take
this in dollars or
in uh bitcoin i think you start to
really highlight the competition at the
monetary policy level of like why would
i take bitcoin over dollars
and educate people for bitcoin i always
recommend to anybody that's not doing
this full-time and even for those that
aren't a dollar cost average
right and there's no better way to
dollar cost average than if you could
say
well i'll take my reward points on my
credit card back in bitcoin
or you know every time i get a payment
on this peer-to-peer wallet i'll take it
in bitcoin or
i'll take 10 or 20 of my paycheck and
take it in bitcoin right like there's so
many different ways you can naturally
dollar cost average if the
infrastructure was there and i think
there's enough demand for that to start
to make sense right like i'd love to see
square look to build something like that
on payroll processing and on
peer-to-peer payments because i would
just have everyone pay me on square cash
and
keep my balance there right you have a
couple hundred dollars a couple thousand
dollars in demo or cash at any given
point in time
convert that to bitcoin and never take
it out right your money's kind of
fungible just keep that as a separate
distinct pool it's just part of your
you know dca allocation which i think is
interesting so great to hear the
blockchain guys are doing that we love
to see them
white label it to all these fintech
companies so yeah everyone can start
getting uh
some bitcoin don't give them too many
ideas they got to stay focused
listen you've uh you've done a fantastic
job i think uh
kind of sharing a lot of your knowledge
uh through the john street capital
account and uh the medium piece that
you've written
help us understand kind of where do you
get the information that you get
in terms of like what are the
information sources that you put um
some level of importance on and then
also what are some of the other things
that maybe you've done
to develop the the frameworks and kind
of intellectual rigor that you use to
evaluate some of this stuff
sure so you know a lot of it really just
comes down to classic mosaic theory like
anything else right you're really trying
to put together the different pieces of
the puzzle so i think
that's again one of the benefits of
looking at both public and private
markets is you can start to see the
future on the private side but it's not
quite there yet you can
see what the public companies are doing
and sort of you know their public
disclosures
it be earnings calls the management
discussion analysis from the case and
the queues and going through that
talking to management teams on both the
public and private side
you know talking to their clients and
you know trying to put the pieces
together
you know what are the pain points and
how are people solving them right and
what is this business doing for somebody
i think
too often in public markets people think
of them
stocks as just numbers and valuations
and ones and zeros and they move up and
down but those are companies those are
companies with employees of
customers and clients that have to be
happy with the product and i think
that's why the work that someone like
kathy wood who i've really enjoyed on
your podcast and the people at arc have
done so well and have been so
differentiated is
you know they have the ability to look
beyond the next quarter the next year
the next two years to say what could
this business actually be worth and they
really treat it like a business
you know very different investment style
and philosophy than someone like warren
bossett but still
similar nonetheless in terms of these
are businesses with cash flows that
you're owning
right which i think is important so you
know it's a mixture of all the above i
think on the private side it's great
because you can get the actual
underlying data from these companies the
more active you are the more information
data you have which you don't quite have
on the on the public side of course
but on the public side given disclosure
requirements there's a ton of
information out there so
you know it's talking to industry
experts it's talking to founders it's
talking to their large customers and
figuring out what paying things are you
know putting the stuff out there for
people to push back and say i don't
agree with that or hear something right
like the number of good conversations
that have resulted of this that have
changed my thinking
are really you know the biggest reason
for doing it right you have founders
gonna reach out to you
like you completely mischaracterize what
we're doing you're like oh okay well
i stopped you know you wouldn't pay
attention to me prior so good
we're having this conversation now um so
yeah that's that's part of it as well
i love that what uh what's the most
important book you've ever read
ah that's a tough one um
i wouldn't say it's the most important
book i've ever read but sort of the most
recent one that was impactful
uh jerry weinstrov has a book when i
stopped talking you'll know i'm dead
uh i for people i don't know jerry's a
self-made guy from the bronx he started
his career as a talent age and he
basically ended up in every role across
entertainment he worked with everyone
from elvis to sinatra to bob dylan the
led zeppelin to clooney and matt damien
and brad pitt
and like he just hustled now it worked
everyone like he literally just talked
his way to the top he had no business
doing anything that he was doing he was
it's probably mid-20s when he started
tore elvis around
um and he knew he had no business doing
it but he didn't care and those are the
always the stories that resonate with me
right like i'm not like
a fan of the smartest guys in the room
long-term capital management blowing
things up i'm a fan of uh
jerry weintraub from the uh the streets
of the bronx just making his way to sort
of the upper echelon of hollywood
i i read that book and it is absolutely
fantastic and uh and he's definitely got
a sense of humor as well
oh for sure uh last question then you'll
get asked me when to finish up
uh aliens believer or non-believer
uh definitely a believer i mean yeah the
universe is just too big for them not to
be here
if you look at all the stuff coming out
on like the ufo project
the pentagon and slowly you know
redacting or unredasting some
information like
uh i think you know you have to think
there's other life form out there it's
just it's just too big not to be
and uh i know that you're intellectually
curious so i'm guessing that you went
and looked it up after the other day
what's uh what's the story with mining
gold on the asteroids
any insights there
it looks like it could actually be
feasible pbd we'll see
elon elon might be onto something
i love that uh you could ask me one to
uh to finish up what question you got
uh so you know you obviously have morgan
creek digital you have the podcast you
have the newsletter this year you
launched the
the youtube channel you have twitter um
you know you rebranded this from
off the chain to to make it more generic
and have some more of these
conversations sort of
what's your goal with all this and where
do you see
sort of the content creators going and
where's your role in that ecosystem
i have no clue uh short answer um
kind of more nuanced answer is uh i just
think that a lot of the content creation
similar to i think what kind of
what you've seen the value of just as
you put things out in the world you get
tons and tons of feedback right and
sometimes they're
um i think it's joe rogan's like don't
read the comments it's uh
bad for you whether it's good comments
or bad comments right it's like there's
definitely that element of just you you
gotta kind of you know
remain uh somewhat grounded in uh in
reality
but what i do find is you know one we
could have this conversation i've
learned a bunch today
uh and i get to do this kind of every
single day with people who are
um you know have specialized uh
knowledge or spend a lot of time
thinking about certain areas so i get
kind of a crash course
um through the podcast and the writing
stuff um i'm shocked at how many people
respond
right and it's just like trying to put a
piece out every day um sometimes it's
not gonna be as great as you know other
days and that's fine you should be
comfortable with that but
um the number of people who will write
back and be like oh today you wrote you
know you wrote about insurance i work at
an insurance company and i actually run
you know
this huge thing blah blah blah whatever
like here's what you got wrong you're
like
cool like thank you right like i can't
believe that you're reading this
um and even to the point of uh like
there's
politicians and regulators and you know
like like all these people who just i
would never
ever think that i would have the
opportunity to uh to kind of talk to and
gain data points from um all that's
really valuable uh
what do i think is the long-term play
for creators in general
uh i think a lot about like creators
used to
uh just create then you had kind of
creators who got smart like oh maybe i
should like make some money by
advertising you know whatever now you're
entering this world of like
uh creators who uh want to invest so i
think like
angelus rolling funds like all this
stuff's gonna like unlock a whole world
of
hey i have a reputation and an audience
so like give me your money and then i'll
go invest
some people will be really good at it
some people will struggle just it's
still investing at the end of the day
right and so that's going to kind of
play out how it does
uh but the thing i'm most interested in
is people who build these really big
brands
uh either personally or even behind like
some sort of you know more
non-personal brand uh and then build
companies um and are able to kind of
type those companies through
and so if you kind of think about uh the
egregious examples that everyone laughs
about or like the kylie jenners the kim
kardashians the kanye west like
yeah they got famous for xyz reason and
we don't think of them as creators as
much as celebrities and they create
companies right then you go and you even
look at
um uh was it ryan reynolds or whatever
with the
the gin company right like he invested
in it but he kind of became the face
ends up uh you know selling it so like
this is not a new mechanism
it's just that we're going to go i think
downstream to kind of the the more niche
players or
or different types of creators so not
necessarily celebrities but actual
content creators
and they've pretty much done this with
like merchandise before you know kind of
like the
the easy low hanging fruit type stuff um
but what happens when all of a sudden
you know the biggest youtuber in the
world creates a software product
right you know and i uh one of the
examples i gave him the other day is
casper
just took a massive down round right
yeah what celebrity
or content creator could step in
tomorrow own that company
and basically completely change the unit
economics because cac would go to zero
right and so it's like you actually can
change the dynamic of a business
and change the unit economics which then
can change the valuation and how
attractive that business ends up being
it's like ddc is an easy one there's
probably a bunch of others but i think
that's a world that is like very
unexplored um but will become
important in the future uh and so like
if you think the world's going there
then like
you should create the content now and
build audience and kind of do all those
things
not having necessarily kind of a finish
line master plan but just like
directionally this is going to be
valuable in the future
right makes kind of sense well you're
doing a great job with it so
uh keep it up where uh where can people
go find
uh the right and by the way i'm gonna
say i would say this without you here
like
uh you probably do some of the most
thorough analysis
uh especially for somebody who post uh
student anonymously
uh it was just ridiculous but when you
read these medium pieces and stuff it's
just like jesus like this took a lot of
time
effort and is obviously very thoughtful
uh so how can people go
find those yeah so you know it's on
twitter and on medium at uh john street
capital
and uh to finish up where did uh where
did john street capital name come from
uh so uh a couple buddies in mind we
were pulling together some money when we
were trying to invest
early on at a school and we lived on
john street new york and
created an llc and it's stuck ever since
nothing like using the really simple
things in life for inspiration
exactly awesome well listen i appreciate
very much and i'll
do it again in the future likewise i
appreciate it have a good one